يوجد اكثر من 2000 ملياردير حول العالم
حتى ديسمبر 2022 بحسب مجله فوكس جميعهم
يتبنون مفاهيم وشعارات محدده يعتقدون انها
السبب في نجاحهم وتحقيقهم للثروات واليكم
اقتباسات بعض اشهرهم من اشهر اقوال بيل
جيتس مؤسس مايكروسوفت التي تتجاوز ثروته
المئه مليار دولار اذا ولدت فقيرا فهذا
ليس خطاك لكن اذا مت فقيرا فهذا خطا قول
اخر من مارك زوكربيرج مؤسس فيسبوك ومالك
امبراطوريه متى يقول الخطر الاكبر هو عدم
المخاطره وفي عالم يتغير بسرعه كبيره
الاستراتيجيه الوحيده المضمونه للفشل هي
عدم المخاطره ورنه اشهر مستثمر امريكي له
اعتقاده شهير صادم يقول اذا لم تجد طريقه
لكسب المال اثناء النوم فستعمل حتى تموت
اخيرا انها برنارد ارنوت رجل الاعمال
الفرنسيه الذي انتزع لقب اغنى رجل في
العالم من ايلول نصب مؤخرا يقول المال هو
مجرد نتيجه لا تقلق كثيرا بشان الربح اذا
قمت بعملك بشكل جيد فستجني الربح